McKenna's here back on the GameSpot live
stage at e3 2014 I am joined by Amy and
Phil we're here to show us a table top
racing a bit of a change of pace from
the game that we were just checking out
which was grim dark fantasy this one's
slightly different for anybody who
hasn't heard of table top racing how
would you describe it jason is a triple
a micro okay it's actually being
developed by one of the original
co-creators of the wipeout series so the
development team are actually based in
Liverpool in the UK they're called play
rise digital and they're made up of lots
of ex-racer developers so they've got
super high racial credentials X Sony
Liverpool studio extras are creations so
definitely worth picking up and the game
itself comprises of eight levels which
can be driven forwards or in Reverse in
Reverse they're a totally different
challenge yeah and there's also
seventeen fully upgradeable cars so you
actually collect coins and coins as you
drive and with those coins you can
basically purchase upgrades for your
vehicles and that can just be
performance upgrades so you know better
acceleration better grip better turbo
you can actually purchase new cars all
together and certain cars are lots of
certain championships but I'll talk
about that a little bit more in a moment
sure and in addition to that you can
also purchase weapon wheels so weapon
wheels are essentially like power-ups
and so it's very much about choosing the
right wheels for the right race and some
examples of some weapon wheels would be
bling wheels so these helped you earn
more coins
oshi race as you would gather from the
now you would gather from the name and
there's also Centurion wheels which are
a lot more old-school
they basically carve up any opponents
that are trying to overtake you in
addition there's piece bomb wheels and
piece bomb wheels are they will strip
all active weapons on track for all your
opponents so it's very very useful and
it should be deployed at the right
moment because it only regenerates once
each lap so obviously it's a combat
racer so there's
for power-ups that you can pick up on
track the speed boost which is quite
obvious you get you out with tricky
situations and can help you out on those
jumps and on those routes in addition
there's mines which you can just leave
on track you can also use them to evade
certain attacks like EMP strike which
creates a circle of destruction around
the car anyone in the way is toast right
and then there's missiles which quite
obvious you can lock onto your targets
in front or essentially anyone who's
behind no one is safe from attack so it
really is interesting stuff so let's
talk about what we actually just
finished a race here oh we're gonna just
adjust your there we go
that's the beauty of live internet so
obviously it's on beta which is why
we're shooting off-screen right here can
you tell us about what what's going on
on screen yes so basically and this is
quick race mode this is one of four
modes that is within the single-player
campaign so quick race is exactly what
it says you can just dive straight into
the action there's four different types
of race there's a pure race for those
more hardcore racing funds there's
combat racing which is what the game is
about at heart and you can also do an
elimination race and a time trial and
then if we if we come out of here we can
also see the additional modes and
single-player so this special event over
30 special events that you can take part
in and they're usually specific types of
races so we outline just a few there
there's also the likes of Time Trial
and hot lap which is just one single lap
that's completely x and some of the
special events are actually tied to
certain cars to just add more to the
challenge there's also a drift mode
which is again three more hardcore
racing fan turn there's also a
championship mode which is made up of
four different trophies and this goes
from amateur right through to expert so
there really is something for people of
all skill levels see we're in the garage
here and as I was saying before here's
all the different weapon wheels that you
can purchase there's 17 different cars
that you can choose from some quite
interestingly names and some cars
actually come with their own special
abilities so for example
and the pegasi carb injection and comes
with its own protective shield the bunny
'mobile actually comes with the ability
to jump so you can accentuate it's kind
of like Dumb and Dumber oh yes which
always helps this is Sharon wagon yeah
exactly right who wouldn't want to pay
homage to her drift drift most
particularly awesome my favorite mode
drift mode a great mode because that's
where you going to earn the most coins
as well okay and I was talking to Nick
Burcham who's the designer of the game
it was the designer of Wipeout and Nick
when he designed the game the best score
I think you ever gotten drift by 150,000
his son he told me that's good half a
million is the world record so it's a
big challenge out there to all Vita
gamers we want to know who can who can
beat Nick Suns record of half a million
something we've not mentioned yet is
it's got 4 player online and poor player
offline local multiplayer which is
awesome for me it really is if you can
handle the madness get online good
advice so we're getting some questions
in the live chat here people are
wondering about platforms is it a Vita
exclusive do you have plans to bring it
to other platforms what's the situation
well it's currently also available on
mobile but this really is the best
version that's out there the guys have
worked really hard to enhance all of the
levels and they've doubled the poly
count on the geometry on the tracks and
they've doubled the texture resolution
and 60 frames a second buttery smooth
and twin sticks no Auto accelerate
exactly and then you can also look
behind you as well so which is very
tactically handy right Robbie Jones was
asking about multiplayer you did cover
that briefly a moment before but is
there a difference in modes can anything
you do single-player be played
multiplayer you can you can play locally
and you can play online against your
friends so whether you want to just get
together with a group of friends get
your visas together have a bit of a
racing party or whether you want to just
get online
I'm just compete in the global
leaderboards it's entirely up to
yourself or the both up both options are
there players to look forward to all
right
a lot of
just like a lot of people who are
excited to see this kind of like micro
racer style game seems to be stoking a
lot of nostalgic memories for people
well the guys really really love their
racing games particularly Micro Machines
and Mario Kart and they really do pay
homage to it you can see the influences
in the game right it's just super fun
let's see here I can't pronounce your
name but Keef rook cry for something
like that
it's wondering is it purely analog deep
egg stare steering or is there tilt
controls any any of that motion stuff
that the Vita has the R is just an
analog steering and but as we mentioned
before there is the rear touch as well
so it does utilize the full features of
the Vita but yeah I mean it's all about
the race and Experion right and I think
because it was a mobile version
initially the guys we're just so keen to
to get in there and and utilize the
controls of the Vita but you can't
change the camera so you can have more
of a kind of a top-down view much more
like motorstorm RC and the controls
slightly changed there because the
camera is fixed alright cool
and I mean let's be honest in a racing
game you want to have the tactile
controls anyways right you just get more
precision out of it let's see here a lot
of basically people are just like
listing off their favorite classic
racing franchise at this point they're
not even submitting questions anymore
it's like all guys remember twisted
metal yeah no it was great
that's awesome well it's good that it's
inspiring a bit of a nostalgia in people
because I think that is what the guys
like really want to do and it's what
they're really passionate about so it's
great that people are excited
so until our audience gets back on track
let's jump back to describing the the
action that we're seeing on the screen
here yeah so and obviously I outlined
the power-ups before I'll just go
through them again and at the moment
there is a mine being used there which
can be used to deploy on track you can
kinda leave it sneakily before a powerup
or maybe on a short court see you know
that someone is going to unfortunately
come across it and they can also be used
to evade attacks that was an excellent
so anyone tries to hit you with an EMP
strike or a missile if you deploy that
mine at the right moment you can
completely evade the attack all together
again looking back and so tactically
handy in that scenario because you can
just place your powerup exactly where
you want it to be exactly the right
moment but it's super fast paced so it's
certainly not for the faint-hearted
right check as well there's also a lot
of shortcuts so it's a lot about
learning where the shortcuts are to cut
the corners and they're all different
when you play in Reverse as well
completely different challenge but
obviously depending on the type of race
that you're involved in and you know for
a speed trial for example you need to
know where those shortcuts are because
as you progress up and the difficulty
gets a little bit more intense you
really need to know that to take it full
advantage otherwise you're not gonna get
your three stars and it does become a
bit of an obsession right it's never
quite enough to just complete a race you
need those three stars you need to get
those coins to get your upgrades and you
need to equip your vehicles ready for
the next race alright guys sounds good
we are out of time at this point but
before I let you go can you let us know
any sort of release date information
that you might have where it's gonna be
out in Summit on PS Pizza obviously and
so everyone keep a lookout for it all
right Amy Phil I appreciate your time
thank you so much thank you so much
thank you thank you